wow do I have a treat for you guys today
I'm holding an original guitar that's
over 180 years old this beautiful
instrument which was likely made in the
1840s was made by Salvador Ramirez in
Malaga Spain you can see it's like quite
the life and that has had many cracks
restored you can see it looks quite old
but still plays thanks to a lot of
people doing Restorations including
Richard Bernay whose shop I'm at now I'm
here with Marshall and Richard and
they've been kind enough to brief me
about this beautiful instrument in fact
I'm very lucky because today I'm
actually recording on this instrument
and those recordings will be part of an
exhibit at the national museum in South
Dakota it is so beautiful to look at and
actually the sound is amazing
thank you
thank you
like a lot of 19th century guitars at
the time the instrument is smaller and
it has quite a mellow sound it doesn't
have this sort of Canon effect that
modern guitars often go for modern
classical guitars that is they're going
for volume this is really not about
volume I think it's about charm
personally the sound is warm
and mellow and Beautiful on the body you
see this amazing Floral Design here
apparently this was done actually to
cover up an accident that the guitar had
at some point in its long life this
patch of wood here apparently is not
original it was replaced on the sound
board this whole thing is a different
piece of wood than the rest of the of
the top and apparently when this was was
done they then put on this beautiful
floral decided to sort of cover it up
the top itself is likely Spruce or fur
the back is made of Brazilian rosewood
which is an exotic rare wood and then
the strip here is this beautiful Bird's
Eye Maple a common wood for backs in the
19th century up here at the headstock
things get a little crazy we have number
one pegs which is characteristic of
early 19th century guitars these
friction pegs you just push in and turn
just like violins or cellos was used on
loots Baroque guitars it's actually very
common and they work quite well when
made well at both ends there's a cap of
ivory the actual design line of the of
the headstock here is sort of a scroll
effect which I have never seen before of
course I'm using gut strings which is
the strings that would have been on the
instrument at the time in fact before
1940 almost all guitars would have had
gut strings and God of course is
intestine usually sheep intestine it's
actually a fantastic sound super warm
mellow and you can feel the texture on
the on the strings if you don't know
about gut strings you can watch my video
all about it here let's listen to a
recording I made of a full piece for
this exhibition this is targa's famous
lagrama
thank you
thank you
foreign
piece but it's so beautiful and charming
and I think it really works with the
Mellow tone of this instrument now the
bridge is actually really interesting it
also has a bit of ivory on it some
inlays here just for beautiful
decoration and then the strings take a
weird path they actually go around the
bridge here going through the back end
then they pop out the the bridge side
underneath the strings which I've never
seen before Richard was telling me that
that's common for some Italian guitars
he's seen on the inside of the
instrument it's like sort of fascinating
world there's all these cleats which are
these wooden patches to sort of
um fix a crack and so there's really a
whole history in here of different
restoration attempts by different
luthiers now the instrument is smaller
than we're used to 19th century guitars
in general in the early 19th century
were were a bit smaller and that's part
of the reason they have the
characteristic sound that they do this
one has a surprisingly good bass range
for the size
foreign
so I'd highly recommend a visit to the
National Museum in South Dakota it's an
amazing Museum filled with loots Baroque
guitars and many other amazing
instruments and if you go at the right
time you might find this instrument with
my video playing next to it thanks so
much for watching if you like this video
please do subscribe my analytics tell me
that 70 of you who watch my videos
aren't subscribed so if you want to help
the channel grow please do like and
subscribe and you'll see my weekly
updates and before we go I want to thank
Richard Bernay for his great work on
this instrument and also recommended me
to record these pieces for the national
museum and also if you're interested in
classical guitar I have an online course
which is six hours long it's a beginner
course it is meant to take people along
their first about six months of learning
the classical guitar and I've heard from
so many of the students who've taken it
so far they seem to really love it and
can't wait for the intermediate course
which hopefully will be out very soon so
please check out the LinkedIn
description for classical guitar Pro and
until next time thank you guys for
watching
thank you